[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oula
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
trois trains qu'est ce qui se passe ici
je sais pas je suppose que c'est une
bombe
une bombe oui elle a été postée ici
juste devant le peuple
qu'est ce que tu penses que ça censurant
les catholiques qui sont vus imposer
[Musique]
m
dans la gamme à l'automne
[Musique]
un enfant de belfast
après tout un enfant comme les autres
qui jouent dans les ruines de la guerre
finalement un jeu auquel rêvent pas mal
d'enfants dans le monde
jouer à la guerre cela ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
cette moto
coli exprimer là il y à des soldats et
là des catholiques se bagarrent un gars
tirer le soldat riposte en tirant sur
deux types qui sont blessés et une
ambiance bien cherché les soldats tirent
des balles en caoutchouc
il y a beaucoup de morts dans ton dessin
ouais pourquoi les soldats ont voulu
arrêter un homme de l'ira et ses amis
essaient de le délivrer
voilà
j'ai toutefois quand il ya souvent des
bagarres comme ça à belfast
qu'est ce que tu en penses
je m'excuse
[Musique]
les soldats anglais tu les aimes tu 2
ils sont dégueulasses
ce qui fait peur c'est l'importance que
le jeu de la guerre qui peut être la
guerre tout court
prendre dans l'esprit des gosses un
dessin d'enfant
cela n'a jamais trompé personne
et moi
sow
you want you
elles ne marchent pas fait tourner le
risque et mme leila ben ali
[Musique]
oui
oui oui
sopra
[Musique]
est on
le tour
[Musique]
nixon
m
[Musique]
après
bien sûr
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
oui
du dessin à la rue du crayon hawkeye ont
peu de choses en apparence
à moins que le jeu ne commence à
s'effacer derrière quelque chose de plus
rien
penses tu que deux jeunes catholiques
communes doivent se battre contre les
soldats anglais ou contre les
protestants à belfast
quand ils viennent dans notre quartier
nous devons nous battre pour les chasser
ils viennent pour brûlé nos maisons nous
sommes obligés de défendre dans ce cas
[Applaudissements]
vous devez vous déformez nous sommes
obligés de vous pour défendre votre la
violence des parts et des bouteilles
tout ce qui nous tombe sous la main
contre les soldats
est ce dangereux pour vous vraiment une
fois guéri il y avait un défilé
pacifique pour les droits civils des
catholiques
les soldats ont ouvert le feu ils ont
tué 13 personnes et aussi une fois ils
ont tué un homme juste à côté du site
ils étaient en train de travailler dans
un point ils n'ont tué deux copains se
sont précipités pour enlever son corps
et le transporter dans une maison
chercher un poste
les soldats leur ont tiré dessus l'un
d'eux a reçu une balle dans la jambe il
a perdu sa jambe l'autre a été tué par
les soldats
j'te soir tout à part de sun est ce que
les soldats anglais ou des protestants
déjà tiré surtout ils ont tiré sur mes
deux frères l'un a été tué l'autre est à
l'hôpital
[Applaudissements]
nous détestons ces [ __ ] de soldats ce
sont des chiens nous oblige à fear 2 on
ne peut pas dormir pour les enfants les
militaires sont les chiens pour les
militaires les enfants sont démontrés
c'est vrai qu'ils ne sont un peu
quelquefois les catholiques comme les
protestants d'un quartier à l'autre
les enfants sont les mêmes les
catholiques peut-être un peu plus sales
sûrement beaucoup plus pauvres
[Applaudissements]
ouais
pas un enfant
au milieu des ruines de belfast c'est le
chaos
un monde de fous août où s'affrontent
les pauvres contre les riches les
catholiques contre les protestants les
enfants contre les adultes qui n'ont pas
compris que l'on n'a pas besoin d'un
fusil tuer un boss et les gosses mobil
perd street était en train de baisser
son rideau lorsque les blindés sont
passés ont arrosé la maison de balle et
on a aussi une en plein front sa tête a
éclaté vous n'oubliez pas ça quand ça
commence et les militaires étaient armés
nous n'avions que les bouteilles des
pavés pour nous défendre
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés les gens se
faisaient tuer devant leur porte alors
lire a essayé de se venger
les soldats sont venus ont arrêté les
hommes de l'ira moi je trouve que la
règle devrait même pour tous les arts
mais regardez celui d'à
regardez toutes les tueries qui en fait
le petit frère d'un de mes copains de
classe a été tué à coups de bâton par
l'uda ou que tu n'aimes pas ton avis y
at il une différence entre un enfant
catholique et un enfant protestants
haine ethnique des chams between you
want chez vous non pas vraiment nous
apprenons tous notre religion dans les
écoles catholiques ou protestants nous
sommes tous des enfants de dieu ton avis
un catholique vaut-il mieux ou moins
bien que protestants non alors que
penses tu de la réaction des adultes
eh bien les adultes
il existe certains adultes dans le
quartier qui sont très bio
il n'aime ni l'armée ni les protestants
ils ne sont capables que de massat de
meurtre et d'effusion de sang
dans le meilleur des cas si cette guerre
prenait fin ils trouveraient encore loin
de se battre pour les 32 comtés de
l'irlande
et si les obtenait continuerait encore
se battre pour le pouvoir ou ceci ou
cela d'abord ils veulent que l'armée dz
ensuite ils se battent contre l'armée
ont fait ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils
veulent
diouf est ce que tu es et des gens que
ce soit des militaires ou des
protestants yair n'aimant pas le maire
ne permettrait pas que je ris qui que ce
soit personne
[Musique]
c'est cela le paradoxe d'une guerre dans
laquelle on en prend enfants à nourrir
personne mais qu'on laisse à la rue un
pavé dans la mare
[Musique]
à